Speaker 1: I want to be really careful with
this next topic, because I bring this up to you,
not because I think it's something to laugh
at, but it's something to take seriously
and to think about in terms of solving the
serious problems that face the country and
that face humanity today. We now have a
sort of combination of different studies
which tell us something that many of us
suspected intuitively, and it's that on
average, Trump supporters aren't that smart, and
I know that this is going to seem pejorative and
that it is going to make many people
extraordinarily defensive, and maybe it's
even going to make people mad at me. But I think
that it's not something to laugh at. It's just a
phenomenon. You know, if the right wants to insist
that intelligence differences exist and of course,
intelligence differences do exist, it's just the
right likes to insist on them along certain lines.
Then they would have to be open to the idea
that intelligence differences can exist among
political stripes. And we're going to look at some
of that data right now and then sort of talk about
the implications are our friend Chauncey Vega
or has an interesting article, a commentary
in salon called new research on Trump voters.
They're not the sharpest tools in the box. Trump's
voters lack cognitive sophistication, often
believe that the Bible is the literal word of
God. And in this article, and I encourage you to
read the entire thing, Chauncey writes as the new
Faith in America survey by Deseret News and Marist
College highlights, the basic and understanding
of the role of religion in a secular democracy has
become so polarized that 70 percent of Republicans
believe that religion should influence a person's
political values, whereas only 28 percent
of Democrats and 45 percent of independents
share that view. OK, so that's a difference
on sort of separation of church and state fair.
But the study goes on to point out Republicans and
Democrats, liberals and conservatives also don't
consume the same sources of information about
news and politics. Conservatives now inhabit
their own self-created media echo chamber,
which functions as a type of lie filled and toxic
closed episode theme and sealed off universe. The
creation of such an alternate reality is an
important attribute of fascism, fascism, and
then goes on to cite research by Darren Burkett,
a professor of sociology at Southern Illinois
University, which demonstrates that America's
democracy crisis may be even more intractable
than the above evidence suggests. In his article,
Cognitive Sophistication, Religion and the Trump
Vote Circuit examined data from 2018 and concluded
there are substantial negative differences between
the thinking processes and cognition cognition
of white Trump voters, as shown in the 2016
presidential election compared to voters who
supported Hillary or another candidate circuit,
observed that Trump's support has been linked to
religion and level of education. But until now,
not to quote cognitive sophistication, which
was found to have a positive effect on voting,
but a negative effect on choosing Trump. What that
means is cognitive sophistication as defined in
this study. Higher cognitive sophistication makes
you more likely to vote. But less likely to vote
for Trump. And the article very interestingly
explains low levels of cognitive sophistication
may lead people to embrace simple cognitive
shortcuts like stereotypes and prejudices
amplified by the Trump campaign. Additionally,
the simple linguistic style presented by Trump may
have appealed to voters with limited education and
cognitive sophistication, of course. Of course,
we suspected that beginning with a Dano's classic
study of the authoritarian personality, empirical
works have linked low levels of cognitive
sophistication with right wing orientations.
Last paragraph and then we'll discuss. Trump's
campaign may also have been more attractive to
people with low cognitive sophistication and a
preference for low effort information processing
because compared to other candidates, Trump's
speeches were given at a much lower reading
level. While much of the Trump campaign's rhetoric
and orientation may have resonated with the poorly
educated and cognitively unsophisticated, these
overlapping groups are less likely to register
to vote or to turn out an ally in an election.
You can read this study. The study is called
Cognitive Sophistication, Religion and the Trump
Vote. It's free to read on the Wiley Online
Library, and I would encourage you to look
at that. So, I mean, listen, it's really
tough to have this conversation because anytime
you're saying a particular group isn't as smart,
it is seen as pejorative and understandably so.
And it is seen as offensive in some way and so
on and so forth. We had this instinct intuitively
that there's no doubt about that, and very early
on there was data pointing in this direction. We
now have some of what I would call evidence or
proof, which is on average, Trump voters are less
cognitively sophisticated. They are more likely to
believe untruths. Look at the study. They are more
likely to be literal believers of some elements
from the Bible. I don't see that and laugh like,
that's not funny to me. I want to solve problems.
And one of the things that I've said many times is
when we have to argue about this is a shorthand.
Dumb things we aren't arguing about or debating
or working towards solving real and complicated
issues when we have 57 percent of the Republican
Party believing that the election was literally
stolen from Trump by Biden and that Trump's
the rightful winner. And we have to, you know,
fend off more than 60 frivolous lawsuits in court
making that case and all of this different stuff
when we're fighting that we're not actually
fixing other problems like, Hey, we've got
a disastrous gerrymandering problem in this
country. As one example, when it comes to voting,
when we are arguing about, is there any of what we
are experiencing in terms of climate change that
we can link to the activities of industrialization
and fossil fuel emissions? When we're arguing
about that and some percentage of the American
public doesn't believe that we aren't taking steps
to actually get off of fossil fuels and live more
sustainably because we're just trying to argue
about the basis of fact. So I don't see this and
laugh, and I know that it's very easy to just say,
Oh, stupid Trump supporters. It's really a much
more complicated issue, and it also relates
to education. It relates to culture. There are
geographical realities here. There is issue about
access to education and health care in so
many different things. So we should take it
seriously. We shouldn't laugh. And again,
much like the anti-vaxxers, for example,
they are a danger. I mean, without a
doubt they are. They're a serious danger.
And they also are victims of disinformation, to
a degree. And as frustrating as we all realize
it is to have to argue with people about, no,
the vaccine doesn't magnetize you. And no RNA
vaccines weren't rushed. It's based on a platform
that allows their development to be faster.
As much as we have to Oregon, it's
frustrating to have to explain this stuff.
They are also victims, and unless we
fix the mechanism that victimize them
to fall for this stuff, just going
to keep happening again and again.